[Music]
Mike good morning let me start you off
with this question that has nothing to
do with the combine if you could sign up
lady on bail or Antonio Brown long term
and you can only have one who would you
sign up long term I think I would do it
the way pittsburgh did it and it's not
necessarily a football conversation but
i think that if you're going to give
long-term money to somebody you probably
want to give it to the guy that you feel
fairly comfortable with won't get in any
trouble won't have any issues he's an
all-pro time now the other guy has shown
some issues off the field and he's been
suspended if you might not be quite as
comfortable handing over X amount of
guaranteed dollars to him so I kind of
feel like they did it the way I expected
they would do it and I think it makes
sense if we just factored in football
not off the field but you still the same
answer well they're both all pros and
they're both explosives and the thing I
like about Bell is that if he plays all
16 games and again that's part of
football is having availability for 16
games which he has shown that he can't
do for that factors into conversation if
he was there all 16 games every year and
had no off-the-field issues because of
what he can do in the past game as well
as the bungees it probably would lead
clean towards him but his availability
is not as good as Antonio Brown I think
we're on the same page with these
quarterbacks I don't think anybody's
ready to start and I wouldn't use a high
draft pick for them by the way mclovin
reminded me Buffalo is taking they have
the 10th pick a girl not the 11 so
here's the over/under for you Mike
number of quarterbacks taken in the
first 10 picks is one and a half are you
going over or under uh I think I think
two could go I'd probably take the over
and you know there's a good chance that
for could go in the first round and it's
too early in the process
but man it's just it blows me away
because handed what's happened is
there's this interesting dichotomy going
on the one hand kids are declaring
earlier and earlier for the draft
meaning they're really not ready and on
the other hand especially if you take
the quarterback in the first round
incredible pressure to play the kid and
the two don't match up and unfortunately
that's where we are right now in the NFL
you know I look at true biscay night
there's not enough sample size there for
me that I can go all in on him deshaun
Watson I like it feels like Buffalo is
going to take him I don't know about
Kaiser I like mahomes a lot but you're
right i think it's so early in the
process that these mock drafts are
misleading because we feel like if a kid
doesn't go where he's supposed to go
then somehow you know he it's on him not
that maybe he wasn't even he should have
shouldn't have been slotted to go there
in the first place but you we always
focus on the quarterbacks is there one
that you feel like are we looking at
safer bets with quarterbacks here as
opposed to somebody who comes in and
starts right away which I don't see
anybody doing that what's the for the
way I've got the quarterback saying
segmented this year is the top four guys
all have in my mind some kind of
first-round talent just to make it
simple they also have different issues
associated with each one of them we get
all whacked out of control with these
mock drafts of it to be honest with you
the more we get into the tape of
quarterbacks and the more the
quarterback coaches and offensive
coordinators meet these kids face to
face that has a heck of a lot more to do
with it then the ability to watch three
or four or five dean who come out with a
mock draft or come out with the top five
list so i think these four kids are
going to get torn apart in the next
couple of months mentally physically in
every other way and what happens is as
teams get to know the kids personally
they start to kind of feel more
confident in one kid than another and
that's just part of the process why is
the 40-yard dash still relevant
you know the hot-button term these days
in all sports is analytics and I think
if you want the NFL version of it the
NFL's into an analytics for a lot of
years just under a different name and
it's the name is the combine and the
reason the drill never changed is
because the NFL values the information
is collected over the last 30 years and
I'm keeping a believer I keep a file
this is how old school I am I keep this
huge file in my backpack that has every
combine result back 2003 and I take it
everywhere I go because I'm always gonna
wait a minute if Tim Williams from
Alabama is the same size as von Miller
and Vicki's Lee and they're all 246
pounds and the two all-pros ran 453 what
stimulated is going to run and to answer
your question that's why that every
single drill is the same and if you talk
to Bill Polian for instance he would
tell you eat leans heavily on those
kinds of numbers because there's a
historical perspective they trust ya but
if I use historical perspective than
Emmitt Smith and Jerry Rice are probably
not drafted where they're drafted and as
many general managers have told me that
fine but you can't build a team on
exceptions because for every nine
running backs that run for six every ten
running back to run for six nine of them
are going to fail you better bet on the
ninety percent not depend least
important combined drill is what least
important combines will it's the they do
free shuttle they do the short shuttle
the three-cone and then they do what
they call a long show which takes up day
and it's basically a 60-yard shuttle
where they go back and forth and to be
honest with you I don't even look at it
I basically don't look at the numbers
all this is an endurance test that means
not who will Christian McCaffrey be
compared to on draft night uh he's a
tough one
for a lot of reasons I think his style
of running believe it or not and I'm not
saying this is who he is but he's style
of running is he's got the best patience
of a college back I peening year he just
his ability to let block set up and
burst reminds me of lady on bail in the
NFL now i'm not trying to save lady on
bail but the fact that he's patient in
the run game and then can also move all
around the chessboard as a receiver I
think there's a style there reminiscent
of lady on bail do you see him as a true
tailback Mike I I see him as a matchup
piece and me for instance Bill
Belichick's the best matchup coach in
history and that's why he signed Kyle
van Noy we've traded away from picture a
white wall he signed her grow away from
Philadelphia either matchup coach and I
think Christian McCaffrey is a matchup
player and you can line them up a
tailback and he's really good I mean but
the way I look at these tailbacks this
year then is for net you kind of put on
one side and down the other side you've
got to look at Dalvin cook Christie
McCaffrey Alvin Kamara don't mix it as
today's NFL tailback meaning yeah
they're going to get their 20 touches
but it's going to probably be 12 or 13
runs six seven eight passes and their
necks today's NFL cornet is more like
okay you draft them you better have a
plan like an Adrian Peterson because
that's what we're in a bit no toxic is
Joe Mixon it's a toxic situation I've
never met the kid and and I think
there's a better way of handling it and
then saying you can't come to our
combine and if I was the NFL number one
I proactively get after these kids and
bring them to the combine that's what
it's set up for set up as a medical and
psychological clearinghouse you've got
the operative ette the kid anyway nepean
because he's going to be in the NFL next
year so you might as well bet him in the
irony to the whole situation is the Joe
Mixon sitting home this week in his own
bed
he's not being poked and prodded for
four days before he runs his 40 and the
whole leg is going to come out anyway it
was pro day next week and he's going to
light it up so he almost has an
advantage not being invited to the
combine one of the guys I love in the
draft is Solomon Thomas of Stanford I
don't know what yep do you think I'm
calling him my guy on draft night if you
want to jump in be in first class on the
bandwagon you want to jump in hahaha I'd
like to be your copilot on that one
that's pretty good you know what's
interesting about him is people want to
say he's Aaron Donald now Aaron Donald
had a freaky combine at 285 pounds I
think he ran for 68 if I remember
correctly at 285 now Solomon Thomas can
play outside he can play inside he's
listed at 273 but when the Sanford
players ran their wind sprints and alder
testing they took him out of the
defensive line because he was too freaky
for them and he ran with the tight ends
full backs and linebackers so you think
you got a good guy there he's gonna run
for 6 40 at the combine he's gonna run
for six he might jump ten feet I mean
he's our loss of action and there's a
lot of love for him in a seltzer have
fun out there Mike and we'll be watching
thanks so much for time that's mike
Mayock NFL network's coverage to the
combine my guy solemn and thomas all in
on it the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience
you